all right okay okay Wow I'm holding a
pumpkin and I wonder this happening yeah
what's up this adventure we've been
preparing for the past like 90 minutes
yep okay give me the someone give me a
quick to a fast here take this take this
I only give long to her and then also
take this before we go if everyone will
stop by the Hang zone I'll give a
motivational need someone to tell me
where the Hang zone is all right give us
like an inspiring speech before you set
off on this adventure you bet does
anyone carrots my first orgy you guys
what if we took seeds it's not really
question if you don't have a mount all
right when I do I was very invasive
that's my salmon cannon yeah that shit's
[ __ ] up I'm the day where that
overtook Epstein staged suicide was
yeah I think they did with those fish
feel like a good 20 years split apart
there was some tomfoolery being head oh
hey it's alright so somebody throwing
another eyes that we're doing I'm gonna
go go a little bit farther because I
don't want to because they shatter
potentially yeah it's kind of like
directly away from the spawn point I
would follow Jacob into hell it's the
only way he goes so that's good my god
Brian do you think the pieces of meat
that are on screen on how much you have
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay I see you guys right it's right
behind me a second ago that lava looks
crazy reflecting on the water back there
I can give you some of these potatoes if
you need but I would prefer on anyone
needs wooden stairs are for things in my
inventory right now and two things are
cold but I start from you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna suffocate I'm gonna suffocate
hold on right click Brian yeah
[Laughter]
definitely still hauling a goddamn
potato and we will let you out roll Ryan
scroll it or just press like there you
go
right click hold right click don't worry
about your really don't need anymore
ender people do okay kept going this way
the way we're going to creep is they're
everywhere
I don't like it oh I hit something else
behind John did you bring no dogs
I did not bring any dog why did you not
bring any dogs this game of jump scares
[Music]
you so many zombies look out look out
zombies are in your head just wait I'm
gonna use my crafting table too big
Brian some iron armor can you use your
crafting table to make him better at the
game I need more potatoes potatoes so
separated so quickly a big ol dick I see
that torch oh yeah I see I see you back
there I see ya I'm here I'm here
Ryan stay in the middle of people I'm
here
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we accomplished very little is everyone
okay is everyone okay Ryan wait friends
are you near the giant disco one well
he's on fire somebody in front of me
[Laughter]
who's the leader the only person here I
trust is Jacob follow Jacob sure am I
wrong landing on top of trees pig don't
worry I got definitely an on accident
I set it on fire but I'll it or chicken
fell it's friends probably check you're
not close to it there's a and so the
nights are full of town met at the red
mushroom mushroom before questing on for
the dragon yes Tom Hanks is not with us
we might travel too far it's still
moving I'm taking the ground root so I'm
taking the trees okay I speak for the
trees a lot of Omar and I are down below
so there he goes careful now yeah okay
there's a clearing outside the forest up
ahead we'll really be in there all right
[Music]
so exciting guys look at you all craft
[Music]
is a cave there that's exciting but
let's not all the people who didn't fall
into a cave like a look at it alright I
show through the I cool I wanna watch it
oh we're back it went bad good that's
good we passed it somewhere between here
in the last place we threw holy [ __ ]
could it be related to one of these
caves maybe that might be way down all
right still there okay up up somebody
positive I got it you want me throw it
again or routing it again yeah we're
gonna throw it frequently now to find ya
all right I'm gonna go this way
do these trees and throw it again we've
Lenny still Barnacle Boy sorry particle
one my chat is right Ilana there is
actually an official welcome do it back
we're back hold up I missed a welcome
okay I'm ready alright well here
everybody I got one it was just to being
John on the server bit weird okay hang
on let me just and up it's like no I'm
just I just wanted to get you all in my
shot so I can watch my welcome to
everyone else I am stop jumping Mimi you
idiot all right oh it's only you that
does here's here's the Welcome dance
welcome Oh as the only woman on the
server I don't know how I feel about
this you summon the darkness you [ __ ]
I'm throwing more yeah I keep throwing
them all right what's what's the
nighttime plan oh it's right there it
just dropped down right below you under
the ground dig all right
shovel all right I'm gonna dig with this
pumpkin make sure we're all connected my
shovel broke I don't have one so I'm
digging with the pumpkin I found the I
found it oh yeah we didn't even explain
there Oh dragon flies around there's
towers that each have little like eggs
on top of them you have to go to the top
of tower and break those eggs because
they heal the dragon